all right joining us now for his first
TV interview since his debate with John
Federman last night Republican Senate
candidate from the great Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania Dr Oz is with us I think it
would be inappropriate to ask you I know
you're a medical doctor to talk about
John fetterman's condition I won't ask
you about that
um but I will ask you this there has
been a great lie here a great deception
here and it was interesting to read the
comments of so many Democrats wow why'd
you have to why why couldn't you just
hide him for two more weeks why did you
have to let him go out on the debate
stage and and it was so apparent to
everybody that it was far worse than
what they were telling the people of
Pennsylvania that argument to me is oh
uh we can lie to win and lying is
Justified under those circumstances
um that bothers me because they're lying
to the voters
well I'll tell you their game plan was
to run the clock out and I have been
chasing down John fetterman since the
general election started to date he has
never answered a question from a voter
on the campaign Trail hasn't answered a
press Gaggle a group of reporters on the
campaign Trail he never obviously talked
to me before I met him for the first
time last night and all I wanted to do
was have him defend what I think are
these eccentric uh and extremist ideas
that would hurt pennsylvanians they're
certainly out of touch with Pennsylvania
values and he has not been able to
defend his dangerous policies so last
night I just put him out there you know
why is it that you seem to care more
about the criminals than the innocent
you wrote you know you asked for for at
least 25 times to free murders over the
objections of other parole board members
and the families he couldn't answer that
the day I did a big event for the
Fraternal Order of Police they're just
asking let us do our job they've all
endorsed me by the way because fetterman
has undermined them so terribly in his
current job I asked questions about why
he wants to decriminalize drugs when we
know that effort has led to a 50
increase in homicides couldn't answer it
why does he want to increase taxes so
much and every job he's ever had yet he
hasn't paid his own 67 times won't
answer it and you showed the example of
fracking where he literally flip flop
backwards and I have to say his answers
seemed almost lazy like he didn't think
he had to answer for things that he's
tweeted out in the past but here's the
part Sean that's going to shock you it
is upsetting that this doesn't be a
duplicitous effort to hide his inability
to defend his extreme positions but he
raised two million dollars yesterday
after the debate from democratic donors
who just want to support him becoming
the 51st senator they know he can't
perform because he can't answer these
questions about his eccentric positions
but they'd want to give him the money to
get him to win anyway so please go to Dr
oz.com get me enough money to compete
with this guy it makes no sense that if
you're unable to defend your positions
and I'm not talking about the physical
stuff I'm talking about literally
telling us why you've said things in the
past that today you now are disowning
but don't acknowledge it why would you
reward that with paying two million
dollars of donations to somebody go to
doctoroz.com and even the kitties so at
least I can get the truth out about John
fetterman more than he lies about me
he's the single most pro-convicted
murderer candidate that I've ever seen
and I started in radio in 1987. I mean
I've never ever heard of a candidate
that advocated for the release of more
convicted murderers in my lifetime and
and other serious crimes anyone wants to
open up a third of the release a third
of prisoners in the state of
Pennsylvania and he has no restrictions
on abortion and yes many times he has
said he wants a moratorium on fracking
no oil leases yes he wants taxpayers to
pay for uh heroin injection sites yes he
does want Pennsylvania to be a sanctuary
State none of that came out literally
the voting has gone on in Pennsylvania
for almost a month now and we've never
had a single tough inner view with John
fetterman we got close with Dasha Barnes
I believe her name is and she was
excoriated for observing the truth and
telling the truth about what she saw in
John fetterman my question to you is do
you think the people of Pennsylvania Now
understand forgetting the health issues
aside how radical he is
oh they're getting the message which is
why we are tied I mean completely tied
now as we head into the last 13 days
which is why please again go to
doctoroz.com and chip in so we can
continue to fight this war but we're
going to win this election because of
what you just asked as voters learn more
and more about fetterman's radical
positions and last night they saw that
he was unable to defend them they begin
to throw their hands up and say this
guy's not like us he's out of touch with
us listen I'm a hard surgeon as you know
we fix big problems the heart and we do
it by working together by uniting people
not dividing them what John Federman
does is take extremism to Washington he
can't work with people he won't get
things done I want balance because with
balance you bring people together yeah
you get Democrats Republicans talking
but instead of bickering which is what
Pennsylvania wants they want us to fix
the problems that are plaguing them
that are hurting them the media is
complicit the media now has allowed this
race to come down of 14 days before the
election early voting had already
started and they all these issues we've
been scrolling his radical positions
they've never ever dug in and demanded
answers and you've been out there every
day and you've had to answer every
question every day on the campaign Trail
and he hasn't answered a single question
and the media is complicit that is their
big donation to All Things Democratic
Party
I think this is about integrity you
should be able to at least own the
decisions and comments you've made in
the past and defend them to the voters
if you're not willing to do it and John
Federman was not willing to do it last
night you don't deserve their votes and
I heard that Sean over and over again
today from independent voters who
actually are trying to decide and they
are now leading our way in a big way
we're going to win this election